jose de leon
is a starting pitcher and he avoids the
chalk but he welcomes the roar
back on the starting bump a one-time big
time prospect
who has since dealt with a couple of
trades he's been dealt twice
and tommy john he is pumped for this
chance
and he is such a warm and inviting young
man that is relishing every moment he
has his family here first time in over a
year
and they are excited to watch him pitch
and the batter is
philip evans cracked out to left
and evans says there it goes wow he
turns it around and the pirates have an
early lead
how about philip evans who in 11 games
last year for the pirates hit 359
he clears the deck here in cincinnati
with a first home run of 2021
and gives the pirates an early lead on a
2-2 pitch what a great swing great
approach gets the two strikes gets the
ball up
elevated it's his best secondary in that
change up
and he does not miss it i didn't know
phillip evans could hit a ball 445
feet look at that here's colin moran i
mean it's this ball in the air to deep
right field going back is castianos and
this ball
is gone clear the deck with another
cannonball
colin moran don't you know all the way
to
cut he killed kenny to give the pirates
a two-nothing lead
there she goes for red beard another
homer
he homered yesterday and he's done it
again pirates with two long balls in the
first
and that a product of that inviting
grandstand at great american
just a great swing great approach you
don't you don't hit a ball like that
and stay through that ball if you don't
have an opposite-field approach
now j.t brubaker gets the ball for the
pirates
he's got some local ties and the reds
only saw him one time last year but he
pitched pretty well in that game
yeah i thought he threw the ball really
well he just happened to lock up against
luis castillo on a night where castillo
was pretty much
unhittable had a weird dichotomy against
sliders last year pull shift on
the pitch is ripped to first good pick
by moran
that's a good sign naquin saw it pretty
well there one down
it was a pretty nice cheer for nick
castellanos coming to the plea
there he softly serves that one over
second that's an old school a b
castellanos goes with it and he's aboard
one down
that's just really good play coverage
castellanos has been absolutely solid
this year but
you know you talk about staying up the
middle evan's fairly deep at third
two on two down so the first big league
played appearance since 2016
for de leon remember his first start
since that time
one two grounded right side it gets
through
the wave is on at third sends down to
the plate polanco eats it in right
india claims third and the reds are on
the board it's 2-1 with men at the
corners
of contact from jose de leon
pitchers helping themselves we've seen
it so far a lot this year there's a
slider didn't quite have the bite on it
de leon just puts the bad head on it and
finds a hole first career hit first
career rbi
and you saw him point to the stands his
family's here
two balls two strikes two outs and two
on in the pitch
swinging a fly ball to center going back
toward the track and approaching the
wall is
fowler and he'll make the catch two
steps shy of the wall
in front of the cincinnati bullpen
behind that center field fence
faces fellow pitcher jt brubacher
and if de leon can do it there's the
first
major league hit for j.t brubacher
somebody get him that ball
get him that ball that's the one that
goes up in the bonus room how about that
for a souvenir night they weren't even
watching
[Applause]
[Laughter]
now that's confidence in your son 2-1
and you come in with a fastball like
that
after a guy pulled you out of the
ballpark earlier now you got a chance to
make a pitch here he could strike out
three consecutive batters with a nasty
one right here
the pitch he got him right down broadway
and colin moran takes strike three
but just when things looked a bit ugly
de leon
comes up huge with three straight
strikeouts
that's now bottom with second mustache
at first brubacher sets at the belt
1-0 pitch bouncing ball to hopper to the
shortstop
and eric gonzalez will toss underhand to
adam frazier for the
final out he's behind the count here one
ball two strikes
the one-two pitch swing and a miss and
de leon
pumped his best fastball right by
offered
94 miles an hour it was up and in offer
didn't have a chance
great sequence there by de leon there it
is again
number one the heater sure the
conversation from tucker barnhart is hey
let's just relax
don't try to do too much one two swing
and a miss he struck him out
fastball in for his ninth strikeout of
the night mike mustakas gets crack
and there he launches one towering shot
to right
fair ball home run well mike mustakas is
what we call
a fastball hitter got a fastball
up out over the plate let these guys get
their arms extended that ball
is going to travel 110.2 miles an hour
off the bat
projected distance 430 feet
tie game 2-1 runner goes swinging to
miss throw down to second
got him by a mile not even close
barnhart nails brian reynolds at second
to end the top of the sit because
was batting when reynolds was thrown out
trying to steal to
end the sixth inning so he gets a fresh
count check
swing on that elevated target he went
appeal to third
strike three uncle fails on this high
fast ball
it wasn't quite as hard as the fastball
before that one in 94
but certainly still served the purpose
three
and two now on nick castianos and
there's a golf shot
deep left field castellanos again
and he is barking to his dugout 5
baseball hello lead 3-2
reds they asked nick castellanos if he
was a leader
he said well i'm not a follower and man
can this guy hit
watch how he celebrates with his team
with his dugout
castellanos feel like it's nba jam time
he's on fire
here's jonathan india oh for three
now a pitch india rips it through base
hit
and padding arrives mustache scores four
two reds in the eighth there he is again
jonathan india getting the ball out over
the plate we get those arms extended
and reynolds sends one out to center
and there it goes a home run for brian
reynolds to start the ninth
and anchor down his first of the season
high towering drive to center field
and it's a 5-3 game two outs
two-run lead 2-1 grounded
shortstop suarez gloves running throw in
time
rock the cradle a.g
bowl game rez